[Musique]
nous sommes à colmar sur le pas de tir
des compagnies hohlandsbourg fondé en
1975 le club de tir à l'arc aligne un
palmarès impressionnant
une trentaine de titres de champion de
france un champion du monde handisport
et plusieurs participations aux jo
paralympiques
elisabeth fait partie de cette élite
mondiale de l'archerie en 2016
elle participait aux paralympiques de
rio aujourd'hui elle partage son
expérience avec les autres tireurs andy
comme valide ici pas de différence entre
les sportifs tous sont réunis par une
même passion
si je peux aider quelqu'un ont filé
quelques conseils dont le don
méconnaissance ce que je connais bien
j'essaie de leur donner quoi pour nous
c'est la même chose enfin on est tous
ensemble n'ya pas les handicapés d'un
côté les valides de l'ofc et met
ensemble quand je vois elisabeth
philippe j'ai beaucoup appris avec enfin
ils m'ont donné des conseils pour
progresser et tout ça c'est génial on en
apprend tous les jours avec quand on
voit leurs expériences qu'ils ont fait
leur parcours et tous et où ça chambre
ça change rien c'est que ce soit des
tirs ben ali de vous des personnes
handicapées ça veut dire ça favorise une
cohésion avantages du tir à l'arc
la discipline n'est pas très compliqué a
adapté pour les tireurs en situation de
handicap emmanuel se définit lui plutôt
comme un tireur amateur il bien pratique
et plus pour le plaisir que la
performance handicapée à la suite
l'accident
geek de son sport lui a apporté beaucoup
handisport a représenté pour moi à titre
personnel un épanouissement à titre
personnel c'est aussi le fait que
lorsqu'on est un handicap
on a bien sûr une control une contrainte
pardon physique qui fait que le sport
nous permet de passer cette barrière et
faire qu'on se sent beaucoup mieux dans
sa tête et beaucoup mieux dans son corps
si je puis dire
la pratique du sport est importante pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
à l'instar des valides celle ci est
bonne pour la santé et le moral mais
c'est aussi un moyen de prévenir
l'isolément
pourtant il n'est pas toujours facile
pour les clubs d'accueillir des
personnes en situation de handicap
honnêtement les clubs ont besoin ont
besoin des jeux surtout pour
pour pouvoir former ces personnes pour
pouvoir accueillir de plus en plus de
personnes parce que ça a un coût c'est
panique
un coût qui n'est pas négligeable pour
ça pour certaines des choses
on reste dans le tir mais on change de
discipline nous sommes maintenant à
illzach pour l'entraînement de sarbacane
sportive ouverts à différents types
d'handicaps cet atelier est animé par
jean paul bret qui préside le comité
handisport 68
son objectif développer la pratique
sportive chez les personnes en situation
de handicap dans le haut-rhin 300
personnes sont licenciés handisport
un chiffre qui pourrait être plus élevé
mais il reste de nombreux freins à lever
des efforts sont faits mais la grande
grande difficulté effectivement c'est de
trouver des cadres techniques des
personne qui veuille bien prendre en
charge d'une personne en situation de
handicap
c'est pas évident parce que souvent
c'est du un pour un ça veut dire qu'il
faut un entraîneur pour un une personne
en dit fort de ce constat le conseil
départemental lancé en mai 2018 un appel
à projet sport et handicap
objectif donner un coup de pouce
financier aux clubs qui souhaitent faire
plus pour les athlètes en dit c'est quoi
cet appel à projets est bien c'est
accompagner les clubs quand ils ont
besoin de formateurs particulier enfin
former en tout cas à ceux à ce handicap
eh bien nous accompagnons ce cette
formation enfin euros la firme laco
finances et puis quand il ya besoin de
techniquement de matériel particulier à
adapter et bien là aussi les clubs donc
font la demande
malgré le le timing très court on a eu
des réponses ça veut dire qu'il ya
vraiment un besoin dans notre
département et c'est le choix de la
présidente et de l'assemblée que de
d'accompagner ce public plus fragiles
[Musique]
depuis 25 ans le conseil départemental
récompense chaque année au mois
d'octobre les haut rhinois qui font
vivre la pratique sportive dans le
département cette année suite à l'appel
à projet sport et handicap se saouler
nombreux clubs qui ont répondu présents
qui sont à l'honneur
huit clubs se sont ainsi vus remettre un
label pour l'engagement auprès des
personnes en situation d'handicap mise à
l'honneur également 27 associations
sportives qui ont répondu présent un
autre appel à projets visant à la
féminisation du sport la pratique du
sport haut rhinoise a toujours été très
forte mais on a constaté aussi bien dans
les collèges
je dans les lycées et même dans les
clubs que la pratique féminine stanier
globalement le nombre pratiquants chute
un petit peu mais on a essayé de trouver
une solution pour stimuler
je pense que cette labellisation
permettra donc à ces clubs d'avoir un
terrain nouveau un terrain fructueux
pour le sport les 35 label remis lors de
la soirée témoigne de la vitalité de
l'engagement des associations sportives
haut rhinoise au conseil départemental
on se félicite du succès des deux appels
à projets via les comités départementaux
on a sollicité les clubs pour savoir
s'il avait des pistes nouvelles ou des
besoins spécifiques et c'est vrai que
cet appel à projet était très fructueux
puisque il a dépassé nos espérances et
que le département a d'ores et déjà
décidé de soutenir en 2019
le complément de ces labels pour l'année
2010 9,7 une enveloppe de 60 mille euros
qui sera affecté à la réalisation des
projets récompensés